well what's your process for developing
an idea I think everyone is different
sometimes you'll get just a logline
sometimes you'll see an image sometimes
you'll get the name of it but not know
specifically what the story is yet
usually what I try to do is like as ice
like I have like this what is it called
speech notes I think it is there's a app
called speech notes and so I'll start to
get information little bits and pieces
about a story
I'll start jotting them down in my phone
and usually once I kind of have a good
idea of what that story is
I always start with the outline like I
anytime before I write a script I always
outline the entire script scene one
scene to scene three and then I'll have
like a couple of a couple of lines of
information to describe this the scene
so this is how I like avoid writer's
block like I always outline the entire
script from front to back so when I
start writing I just write from from
from that those script notes but yeah I
usually start there I start with just a
an idea outline it
I always decide early on what the
lighting is gonna be how the camera is
going to move to color everything like
before I even go into pre-production
like I I am I have a full idea of the
style the look of it the pacing of it
the tone of it and yeah once I do that I
start writing the script I have a team
that I work with and I usually tell them
pretty pretty early on like what the
what the concept is and how I want to
approach it and
yeah I sorta sort of go from there you
have a pretty deep intuition yeah yeah I
am I always have a really good idea
what's gonna work I think like you know
I'm constantly looking at the market and
how I would respond certain things and
you get a good idea of like okay this
might not be a great time to make a
Western you know versus versus hey like
a superhero thriller might feel really
good right now you know that sort of
thing so yeah I always sort of watch
what the markets doing and it's usually
pretty in line with my tastes as a as
just a film goer like the kind of stuff
I like to watch and then you have to
sort of project a few years out because
it might take a few years to get that
project done so you almost want to
[Music]
whatever that story idea whatever your
approach you take you know you almost
want it to be a few years ahead of where
you are so that by the time it's all
ready does it feel stale it doesn't feel
old or outdated say yeah Julie prophetic
intuition ever led you to something that
actually existed already like a real
life story like you were so tapped in
and then you realized oh wow that really
happened and it kind of surprised me
more not as a as yet like because I like
to be informed about things like I'm
very much every day I'm always like
seeking out new information or staying
up on new tech as far as filmmaking the
gear and then just like what's going on
in the world but I I do like this sort
of sometimes I like to pull
things from what's going on in the world
and sort of twist them a little bit so
that so that it is there like there is
an underlying thing that might be there
concerning something going on in the
world but um I tried to be telling those
with it you know because I do want it to
be entertaining I try not to be overly
political because I know I know people
get sensitive about that when you put
like way too much politics in your film
people have like strong reactions to
that sort of thing so I just want to
entertain people and maybe have them see
things a little bit differently than
they may have before but I don't want to
I don't want to preach to them that sort
of thing is it hard to do that though
because right now like our culture is is
turning so much whatever side
quote-unquote side anybody's on you see
it in the youtube comment we didn't used
to see that before yeah it wasn't
brought up whatever quote side somebody
was on yeah it's super political now
I mean it's and so the thoughts that you
may have to anchor as a factor of how
the world is changing and it's becoming
in us against them again whoever side is
them and whoever side is us
yeah that's how it seems like we're all
viewing not all of us but a lot of
people what we're kind of it's seeping
into the culture so as a father that's
writing about it yeah I think um I think
you can touch on some things without
making a concrete sort of this is the
way that you know that sort of thing I
think you can touch out certain things
and and you know you can see a little
bit of that influence there without
picking without jumping on either side
you know what I mean just sort of just
present a point of view I think
and without hopefully offending anyone
it was very difficult
nowadays but I usually try to deal with
themes that are more universal so it's
it's less just sort of folk less
localized and less focused on just one
particular group or point of view and
because I think universal themes like we
all can relate to we can all connect
with like a universal themes of love
wanting to protect people you care about
doing the right thing in a lot of cases
or some people doing things that are
wrong but they feel they're justified or
they feel they're right so a lot of
those sort of overarching themes I try
to play in that spectrum you know yeah
cuz I cuz I want to make my films with a
for like a global market I don't want to
create things that feel too localized or
too like I'm excluding different groups
of people
you think the martial arts effected that
just the balance staying more in the
middle yeah I would I would say so I
think it's helped me in so many ways I
mean even in its the the physical part
of it is really small in comparison to
the spiritual aspect of it and then the
discipline the self discipline that sort
of you know the the way that you sort of
see everyone as being like we're closer
we're more like than we think we are you
know what I mean
and being a teacher for so many years
like having so many different people
that you interact with and you become
really close with you start to realize
that
I think I think that's affected the way
that I make homes as well like a lot of
times we're just super misunderstood
like you know and sometimes we're not
listening to other people we were only
trying to get our point across and we're
not seeing their point of view you know
everyone's intentions aren't bad you
know they they just might you just may
not understand their intentions and I
feel like you know that that plays
really well with that's funny yeah I
think that that plays really well in
film because you know it's very uh it's
all about what you get from it and it's
all about sort of what you take from it
and and different people will take
different things from it you know what I
mean so yeah I think that's the really
cool thing about being a storyteller
it's like you can tell the story and
it's gonna affect people in different
ways you know I'll never forget like my
first screening he was the first film I
made it was called champion road and it
was back in 2006 I produced that film
and came out in 2008 and I had a
screening I like a local theater
screening and this guy came up to me
afterwards it was it was about so
basically was about this guy who his
wife was was dying and she needed an
operation and they couldn't afford it
and so he he wasn't even a fighter he
was just a guy you know but he put his
he put himself in harm's way you know to
save her afterwards this guy came up to
me and he said man you know what like he
had he's been having issues with his
wife like they'd been arguing and I
think through it he realized like how
petty
he was being and how like how much he
did care for her he was like man I'm
leaving here and I'm gonna go get my
wife back and you know he was like I
just want you to know that you know I
just felt like that was it like no
matter what else happens with this film
like that was so cool so worth it
you know yeah that meant more to me than
like everything else that happen with
that movie